I want to introduce Lynn rut she is not
only the founder of pie lady San
Francisco she is an amazing developer
who does outreach who does really cool
stuff really help move the Python
community forward in San Francisco and
now she's here to teach us how to spy
with Python give her a hand Thank You
Cindy and hopefully my slides will show
up in a second um but I have I have it
it's a short presentation I'm going to
so I'm going to take up a couple minutes
in the beginning just to like say a
couple announcements and so I work at
spotify I'm engineer at spotify and I
just want to say that we're hiring in
San Francisco and New York and Stockholm
both back in in front-end engineers so
if you're interested you can talk to me
or email me at lynn at spotify com um I
also want to do a little shameless
promotion of Pi ladies of San Francisco
we have a few events coming up that
might be of interest to you all the
first event coming up is actually
tomorrow evening it's in the San
Francisco at the Spotify offices zedge
Shah from learn python the hard way is
coming to chat with us so it's monday
evening and we also have like a crash
course of like linux unix like CLI tools
coming up in june and a workshop like a
full stack workshop coming up in july
both in san francisco and then we also
do a lot in the bay or south bay area on
i think thursday we have yeah thursday
at linkedin i believe is a study group a
monthly citigroup and then the following
week on tuesday is a hackathon which i
also all encourage you to go if you want
more information it's meetup.com / pi
ladies SF um also for for a woman out
there we have a little promotion going
where if you want to go to Google i/o um
you can apply by this friday and you can
get a ticket for 300 bucks if you can
arrange your own travel and stuff
that I mean it's all up to you but
offering google i/o tickets for for 300
bucks more informations on pi ladies
calm and then I actually announced this
at PyCon a few weeks ago pip install pi
ladies which is pretty awesome it's if
you want to start your own pilot is
locally you can install the PI ladies
package or I can go to kit Kylie's calm
and learn how to start your own pie
ladies i know that SF does a lot of san
francisco city pilotes and south bay
patties but there's not a lot of like
East base of someone wants to start like
an East Bay hi ladies i would be great
we can go to pip install pi ladies and
should should help you up anyways um so
um i have actually i didn't think that I
would pardon Oh yesterday's ladies yeah
yesterday's ladies women are high school
women workshop I was just a mentor
there's actually Cindy who introduced me
that love that which is a lot of fun and
I I just want to say that I wouldn't
have thought to actually like come here
to PI data because i'm not i'm not into
like doing a lot of work with data and
python although i think data and pythons
a lot of fun i don't do it for my day
job but i want to thank james powell i
don't think he's in here and Leah cilan
I don't think she's in here either for
convincing me to submit this talk and
I'm so glad I came because I did get to
work with the high school women
yesterday for the workshop and I'm
learning a lot here like ipython with
like our kernel and haskell kernel and
it's like wow so I'm actually really
excited to go home and play with it so
yeah so the this presentation wouldn't
happen with people egging me on I've
done this presentation before but I
didn't think that um it'd be PI data
like but then I was thinking well we're
inspecting packets and data packets and
stuff like that so yeah it's kind of fun
and a little tongue-in-cheek kind of
presentation so so I hope that you enjoy
it
so yes so this is called um how to spy
with Python so easy the NSA can do it um
so so yes i am lynne route i am a rogue
glenn on twitter and this presentation
you can find at rogue li / spy I've been
slightly updating this presentation
since I've started a maybe a few months
ago so this is the most recent one so
Who am I am so you kind of introduced me
already but I'm a partner engineer at
spotify i build api's for partners to
consume i also like like lead
integration projects for third-party
folks as well as i get to do PI ladies
during my job and speak at conferences
for my job so Spotify is awesome if
you're looking for for work pilot ease
of San Francisco I also help pilots
globally and starting other locations
internationally and in other states and
I am board member of the Python software
foundation all right so I have to start
off this presentation with an obligatory
disclaimer i am not affiliated with any
of this alphabet soup and a say FBI CA
whatever i am also not a lawyer and I'm
not a black or a white hat and this is
literally just a proof of concept okay
look there's me so today's talk will be
I'll first start off with some
historical context I also will go into
what the NSA is doing lately or that we
know of including what prism is in what
xkeyscore is and then go into some
unanswered questions that that we have
from what the NSA is doing and basically
how you can do that how we can do that
with Python so what this talk is not
it's not condoning what the NSA is doing
it's not how to avoid being tracked by
the NSA and it's not encouraging you on
how to spy on friends family or anywhere
where there's free Wi-Fi however that's
exactly how i did this presentation
where i went to like cafe and sniffed
Wi-Fi
um so let's start off with some
historical context basically what the
NSA is doing with prism is nothing new
um so we'll start off in early nineteen
hundreds actually the five eyes group is
comprised of the USA the UK Canada New
Zealand Australia and the purpose is to
share signal intelligence or each
country would surveil a set of other
countries where like the US would focus
on Latin America and then and then share
with each other and so while the u.s.
does not technically spy in itself
technically there's no stopping Canada
from sharing data that it collected
about US citizens with the US government
so the NSA was established officially in
1952 but actually kind of started back
in world war one when the US declared
war on Germany it morphed into the Armed
Forces security agency after World War
Two and the AF sa we designate itself
into the NSA in 1952 after it couldn't
really get its [ __ ] together it didn't
really know what I was doing and then I
got some new ordinances and so it
morphed into the NSA and so over 20
years after the NSA was officially like
designated officially established and
over 50 years after the start of the US
surveillance the Supreme Court finally
required warrants for domestic
surveillance so there was a long period
where domestic surveillance could happen
without words fears after the Church
Committee revealed illegal domestic
spying by the NSA in 1975 the Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Act was signed
to protect Americans and with that a
secret super secret court which we all
know about is the Foreign Intelligence
Surveillance Court was created for the
purpose of hearing request for these
warrants and so shifting over moving
forward to 2001 after
9 11 World Trade Center attacks the
culture against buying began to shift
within the NSA so within the first month
of right after September 11th White
House asks the NSA what more could be
done against terrorism if the NSA had
more authority the NSA resurfaces a plan
to perform contact chaining on metadata
that it collected originally deemed
illegal only a few years ago by the few
sack on the US president that gives the
NSA authority to begin targeting Terrace
associated foreign phone numbers
continuing on within that same month the
US President and cabinet sort of
scrambled to draft an authorization to
spy on Americans as none had yet existed
despite the NSA Inspector General report
detailing but this is already happening
and so then Bush signs the order to
allow the NSA that new spying program or
that resurfaced spying program and now
the NSA feels it's authorized to spy on
us calls and emails without warrant and
so then the US Attorney General is just
given that authorization told to just
sign it we need to do this we need to
get over with his national security so
blindly signed it shortly after that
telecoms and domestic spying started um
unrevealed telecoms in internet
providers and the u.s. received letters
from the NSA requesting data to support
its domestic spying program and then
there are an 18 team play discovers the
NSA is working inside on 18 to san
francisco facility and then after that
and telecoms formally enter into a
voluntary agreement to give us with us
to give data to the NSA and then related
to that ATT employee an installation of
super-secret special technology in the
secret room room 641 a
and that SF 18t facility was in solid
two to read and analyze tens of
thousands of communications per second
and then send those off to super secret
database that the NSA controls and so
2003 a total information awareness act
program freshly started 2003 but it
actually sort of started in development
in two thousand and am to gather
detailed information about individuals
to anticipate and prevent crimes and so
Congress actually stops that in 2003
deeming it sort of illegal but the
program sort of is quietly separated and
moved into various various committees
and is now under the NSA domestic spying
program so it the total information
awareness act is still going on and all
right so now we're up to two thousand
five 2007 the NSA is exposed so in
december two thousand five of the New
York Times reveals that the NSA has been
spying on Americans without warrant and
soon after bush confirms that the NSA is
indeed more lessly wiretapping folks the
New York Times also reveals that some of
the NSA spying is purely domestic with
some telecoms giving backdoor access to
communication streams I guess I
mentioned before the 18 th San Francisco
facility and soon after the times
article an unknown company requested the
NSA to issue court orders now rather
than companies voluntarily handing over
data so back 2002 2003 telecoms are
voluntarily giving data to the NSA / the
requests and then now after all this bad
press there now requesting warrants 2007
the protect America Act was passed
allowing them to say not to need
warrants alright so coming up to no data
protection our data collection for prism
starts with Microsoft in September 2000
2008 the Congress passed amendments to
the FISA act by gives of telecoms legal
immunity for those that cooperated with
the NSA's wiretapping 2012 on essays
sites building its biggest spy Center in
Utah for its collection of intercepted
data also in 2012 the FBI pushes for
wiretap ready websites asking internet
companies to not oppose a lot making
backdoors mandatory and then 2013 if we
remember the Washington Post exposes the
prism program and shortly after
xkeyscore was revealed so that brings us
up to up to today and the past few years
actually and so let's quickly go over
what prism is so prism stands for a
planning tool for a resource integration
synchronization and management lots of
words that make sense but bureaucratic I
guess naming system but doesn't really
make sense so what it actually is is it
mines electronic data for the purpose of
mass surveillance it clicks intelligence
that passes through us servers because
I've seen like maps of like internet
cables a lot of internet traffic passes
through the US even if it's going from
like UK to Germany and so it supposedly
targets only foreigners but it's very
elusive about the data that it collects
on US citizens and supposedly only and
collects metadata so xkeyscore pairs
well in their eyes with prism it's a
digital network intelligence
exploitation system it's basically a
federated query system that I completed
of completely unfiltered data so prism
collects the data and xq scores were
like the database that allows you to
query as of 2008 they had up to about
700 servers which is not a lot but not
as i mentioned 2012 they started
building the utah center so I'm sure
they have many more by now
and it gives users bc folks that work
for the NSA the ability to query for
email addresses a target's activity
phone number is HTTP traffic extract
file attachments etc so this leaves us
with some unanswered questions what
exactly does metadata mean and then how
did companies not notice being
backdoored or are they lying when
they're denying cooperation how is the
targets foreignness determined how
exactly are they identifying non-us
citizens and then what's being done
that's accidentally collected a data
that's accidentally collected on
Americans and so also how is the prism
collected data handled by the NSA does
the NSA maintain rigorous security
measures to protect against threats like
all the data collected on me by accident
is it nice and secure can someone also
hack into that and so one of the
questions that I asked earlier was what
exactly is metadata and I actually kind
of stole this slide from the eff
presentation at 30c 3 in Berlin in late
2013 so metadata is is that they know
that you rang a phone-sex serve as a 22
my 4am spoke for 18 minutes but they
don't know what you talked about they
know that you called a suicide
prevention hotline from the Golden Gate
Bridge but the topic the call remains
secret and I know you spoke with HIV
testing service and the new doctor and
then your health insurance company
within the same hour but they don't know
what was discussed so you can see that
like that's all metadata that it doesn't
tell you what the conversation had like
actual date of the conversation that
happened but you can glean a lot of
information based on that and so we kind
of know what sort of data that are
getting but how are they getting it and
so this is presumably how it's being
happened is through the tier 1 the
backbone of the internet and so the tier
1 um Internet allows vast amounts of
data to flow from one min point to the
other
through the simplest path versus
consumer internet which hops around
looking for the cheapest path and so
major companies like Facebook Google AOL
Microsoft are able to tap into the tier
1 network through entry points called
edges and then so rather than walking on
to Google's or Facebook's data centers
and being noticed i'm going to say just
sort of wiretaps these edges between
major companies and the tier 1 network
so I'm sure you all know that there's an
XKCD comic for everything so it probably
actually happens like this where you
think that you can you know crack some
RSA like encrypted laptop and really
it's probably just brute force with like
beating people into submission all right
so now the fun part how you can do it I
want to make sure that we look the part
so I got like my little jacket you know
let's see I can like put my scarf on I
don't think I look like a good hacker do
I pass yeah I want you to be able to
hear me and not like mess up nice um my
speaker thing so anyways um so tools
that I used um this actually this
presentation is done like Python I did
everything in my Python and then ipython
notebook has an awesome a flag that you
can use that generates slides and this
is the product of it I also use scape e
which is packet sniffing and
manipulation for these exercises and
then I also use PI geoip which is the
API a python api for geoip databases geo
json with bindings and utilities for geo
dis one in a Python and map a wrapper
around the internet port scanner and
then if you wanted to play along I mean
this whole presentation is on rogue deli
/ spy but everything else I mean if you
just go to this website you can go to
the slide and see
all the links of the ipython notebook
I'm doing quick entropy as well as going
through every exercise mimicking what
the NSA is doing as well the last link
is a complete repository of these
notebooks I'll show the first leg again
at the end alright so a quick
introduction to Skippy so this makes me
cringe but um this is documented from
Sky be all import star and so I want to
sniff some traffic that only goes over
HTTP so I'm limiting I'm sniffing with a
filter of tcp / port 80 I'm the
interface i'm using is just ian 0 which
is my wife I traffic and I'm limiting to
10 packets and so if I see what a is you
can see I got indeed 10 TCP packets and
if I want to see the complete response
you can see sort of a barf of all this
data that kind of doesn't really make
sense yet if I just grab the very first
packet you can see a little less
information kind of looks interesting
and escapee has this awesome new
function or method called show and so a
pretty prints basically this packet so
you can see the ethernet layer the IP
layer the TCP layer you can see um you
know so IP addresses and protocol let's
see there should be some flags likes
like act flags yeah there's some Flags
to so I mean that that's basically how
i'm using skippy this is all that you
sort of need to do what I'm going to be
doing so example xkeyscore queries as I
mentioned before xkeyscore is a database
that kind of hosts all the information
collected from prism allowing users of
the NSA to query what they want so this
this queer following examples are from
the presentation of to its employees
let's see if this works yeah so this
presentation I mean this looks like crap
but this is what the NSA gave to its
employees and basically showing how to
execute
or works and I'm basically taking
exactly this but making prettier slides
and how you can do that in Python so so
then these are just a proof of concept
i'm not actually storing any data and
then again I'm not condoning on spying
friends family or anywhere where there's
free Wi-Fi except that's exactly how I
did it so first query that xq score NSA
folks presented was show me everyone
that has searched for a certain term for
y term and so I have a pretty safe pcap
file a cat file and then you can sniff
offline with scaping again I'm using the
sniff function or you can actually live
sniff I guess you're on traffic with
this filter of TCP and I'm limiting to
the house of searched yahoo com I'm
limiting to 300 packets and then you can
actually save it for later and so the
packets look like a you can see again I
have 300 TCP packets a quick summary of
these packets and you can see a full
list of everything where it goes package
0 goes from ether IP tcp from IP address
and port to IP address over HTTP
protocol and you can see the flags and
this i'm picking packet 79 and just
quickly showing it again you can see the
ethernet layer the IP layer the TCP
layer and then raw load which we didn't
see before but it kind of looks
interesting we can see get requests and
some information down here so let's sort
of parse that out so if you just grab
the raw layer again this is just
grabbing that information um oops sorry
and then if you sort of parse that raw
layer out a little bit when I was
playing with Yahoo and search queries I
noticed that whenever you put in a query
like the
the URL has a ? p equals and then the
search query so i just saw that from the
URL bar parse that out and the reason
why i used yahoo is because it was not
over a cps like google it was over HTTP
i think they changed that but so i can
see that my first query I searched for
Madrid / / yahoo just by sniffing and
traffic and then my second query i can
see that i was just searching for i love
chocolate I really was not creative and
then the last one I search for his blue
bottle coffee so basically this is
showing that like I can open up Skippy I
can sit on Wi-Fi like Facebook and sniff
what you guys are searching for if it's
over HTTPS it's a little bit more
difficult as i do not know how to
exploit the heartbleed bug yet but um
that's possible alright so query number
to show me um everyone from a certain
country that has visited a certain
extremist form um so from scaping import
star I have this htp cap file already
you can see at the second line that you
can use this filter of TCP and host 8888
with them 100 packets count and so again
here i have a 41 pack TCP packets into
UDP i'm showing the third packet you can
see some again the raw load data so if
we're just parsing that out you can see
exactly the HCP like headers let's see
here and if like if this was like a
query of actual database you want to see
if someone visited the former Wireshark
website it's pretty pretty simple and
then so what I did was I took the
packets and basically traceroute them
sorry that you can't really see all this
but basically this is my makeshift
traceroute function and so I was able to
get all these IP addresses from trace
rotting plotting the IP to latitude and
longitude and so getting coordinates you
see a bunch of pairs of coordinates and
then making a geo JSON file out of these
coordinates um and then just like using
that function and then here's a geo JSON
I guess that's like file that I would
save then you can actually upload that
to just get hub and I automatically plot
for you so you can see like the
traceroute of that like request the
searcher clarity I get requests and i
think when i did this i was actually in
stockholm so you can see like a point up
in like sweden area and it goes like
back and forth and that does illustrate
that even if like the server is in like
UK and I'm from I'm doing it from Sweden
that it's going still going overseas to
through the United States up right it's
pretty cool now going to the next query
grey three show me all emails with a
certain term in the body of the email so
i have smtp pcap file here's a summary
of it you can see sort of UDP packets
DNS queries and smtp traffic just
picking out at the eleventh packet I'm
getting the raw data of that and you can
see that it kind of looks and coded so
I'm going to take away the null
characters of that um I think it kind of
looks like base64 so I Dakota that you
can see an email address let's take a
look at the next packet see if we can if
it's also encoded and
again kind of looks encoded so you can
see if we decode it it's a password
prompt the next packet if we take that
raw layer I wonder what this is right
after password prompt what could it be
and it's the dudes password this this
the sample smtp pcap file is actually
uploaded to like Wireshark database so
I'm sure this guy knows that his
passwords up there and has since changed
it but this is just goes to show that
it's actually quite easy to like parse
out email headers in raw love the road
so I want to see if there's a certain
strings within the email within the
within yeah the raw load of the email
and i want to see if attachment is in
that email and so using my quick and
dirty function I found the query you can
see this is actually the whole email
these are all like the headers the
metadata of everything so you can see
the from the two and a bunch of other
headers you can also see that the
attachment is indeed in the email like
that string and then if you scroll down
further this is actually the attachment
that was in the email so I'm physically
reading the attachment so that's kind of
scary I'm query for give me PGP usage
for a certain country I made a sample
PGP email saved it real quick reading it
you can see that p-gp emails do not
encrypt any of the metadata it just
encrypts the body because how would
how'd your house be able to route it
right so it's not like to secret if I
mean if you really wanted to be super
secret and you wouldn't include anything
in the subject line it probably just be
like stuff and
and PGP encrypted body or like if you
really wanted to like avoid being track
maybe like a private forum that doesn't
have any data of yours on there and
actually email through that but that's
getting kind of tin foil hat like
anyways you can see that like from like
you can see where it's from received all
like the headers and then the actual PGP
encrypted part is the body and basically
all that you need to do is to see if
this string is within the headers and it
basically tells you that yes this is PGP
encrypted and then let you know you can
my quick and dirty parser / trace route
we can see that see my friend was in
Germany when I did this and I was
actually in Sweden why did this so it
came from like Berlin and went to like
Stockholm area but then again it went
like pretty much back through the USA
and then and then where I was so it's
quite obvious that the u.s. could
intercept the PGP encrypted email even
if it's not going to not starting our
ending in the US let's see curry number
five show me chats for certain user
during a certain time frame and so I
have a sample another sample cap file
for IRC chat I have 1,150 packets and
some UDP packets icmp packets and others
if we do show you can see the lots of
TCP stuff the port that's very familiar
for IRC DNS queries you can see freenode
which is typical of IRC and then if we
do some pretty printing of of everything
you can see like some chats going from
IP to IP if you parse that out just a
little bit further and want to this is
my filter string and filtering for user
amarak
and then you can see these chats right
here where you can see mr singh how do
you mean a whatever like so you can see
like messages over IRC pretty pretty
simple pretty easy re season at the
safest protocol how r find all
exploitable machines in a certain
country now I'm not going to tell you
how to exploit them i'm just going to
show you how you can find something that
might be exploitable um so i use n map
which is a python wrapper for in map and
i'm scanning a bit bucket actually
between port 22 and 4 for 3 um it gives
you this sort of data dump it includes
the command line if you just wanted to
run into your command line and then
let's hear you can see the IP addresses
hostname it was able to find that port
25 is open which is used for smtp is
able to find port 53 open which is bind
dns able to find 80 which is engineers
runs on 110 for pop 143 for imap 443 for
another in genetics ssl so if you happen
to know that this version of engine dex
one point five point three is
exploitable which is listed publicly on
those it like metasploit or something
you can you can find that and then you
can go do what you want to do with what
you just found so it's quite easy to to
see what what ports are open and what's
running behind those ports mind you that
I did this one time and then at reddit
it five minutes later in bitbucket
blocked me so and so all the house for a
bit bucket is just just one IP address
I'm going to plot this with PI geoip
again creating a geode JSON file and
then here's the Geo JSON file that I
created and if we plot that
you can see that this server is actually
near Denver Colorado so even maybe you
don't have a technical prowess to
exploit engine X or something but you
know the physical location you can maybe
do some like muscle stuff and break in
or I don't know all right so I'm
wrapping up had a lot of fun we learned
long historical precedents for mass
surveillance with very little oversight
or restriction safe to assume that the
NSA is pretty much spying on everyone a
conjecture of how the NSA is actively
backdooring communications and kind of
how to get yourself on the no-fly list
although I've never had issues and then
how to implement your own sort of prism
and xkeyscore with Python all right
that's it thank you very much
so there's only like it's only like two
minutes it looks like one or two minutes
maybe one question I'm I'm just
wondering where do you run this cold I
mean when your traffic goes through it
goes through multiple hops we're
actually do you run this code it's on my
computer okay so you're you're watching
your own poor visibility exactly yeah I
could I can go into a promiscuous mode
or something and go and sniff everyone's
traffic if I wanted to but like within
like 10 seconds I'd probably get like
over 10 gigs of data that that's exactly
the following question is if you look at
this deep deeper traffic is very verbose
and free you know broad street traffic
so this kind of quarters get into
trouble to deal with that kind of
traffic all right thanks Andy yeah I
just have to say that was awesome that I
would have taken me like six months to
find all that history and that was an
awesome tour of the internet protocols
and how to play with them that was
really awesome thank you
all right um so I'll be here for a while
if you want to come find me I also have
pie lady stickers if you want I have
plenty of them but yeah come come talk
to me thank you very much and and just
so everybody knows there's about to be a
keynote by Josh bloom back in living the
dream he's going to be talking about
data science at Berkeley that's back at
living the dream where you first came in